If you traveled to the deepest points of earth, what would you find?
Lost cities, mythical, sea monsters,
rivers of gold. Probably not,
but there's still a lot to discover. So join me.
As we traveled deep,
underneath the surface to explore some of the most inhospitable
places on earth,
what lives at the bottom of the Mariana trench,
how much of the ocean is unmapped and
what is mined deep below the earth surface?
This is what if, and here's what would happen if you explored the deep,
this points on earth?
Not many people can claim that they've been to the deepest point on earth,
but Victor [inaudible] from 2018 to
2019,
the Scoville led an expedition that visited the deepest points in
all five oceans.
The five deeps expedition covered 87,000 kilometers in just
10 months and completed 39 dives using a small submarine
for your trip. You're only going to visit one trench.
The Mariana trench you'll need to save about three quarters of a million
dollars for the trip,
but you'd be one of the few people to explore this deep.
What would you say I see as you descend first,
you'd need to travel to Japan from there.
You'd take a submarine about 2000 kilometers out into the Pacific
ocean challenger. Deep.
The deep point of the Mariana trench is almost 11 kilometers
below the surface,
and it would take about two and a half hours to reach it.
There will be a lot to look at in the beginning of your descent.
The first 200 meters below the surface is where most ocean life
thrives. As you travel deeper,
it becomes darker and the less wildlife you'd see
though, you still get to witness the occasional whale diving for food.
You'd see your first deep sea creature,
the Fang tooth at one kilometer below the surface.
This appropriately named fish is 16 centimeters long with
two giant teeth to make room for them.
The Fang tooth has two sockets beside his brain.
As you travel deeper than 2,500 meters,
there are no more whales. They don't usually dive down this deep,
but when you hit 8,000 meters,
you'd encounter the Marianna snail fish. At this point,
the atmospheric pressure is nearly 1100 times what you feel
at sea level. If you weren't inside a pressurized submarine,
it would be like having the weight of a fully loaded truck on your head.
Those little snail fish out there must be pretty strong to withstand all this
intense pressure. Eventually you'd reach the very bottom.
The challenger deep. If you look closely,
you might spot an amphipod species or run the Lake Gigis.
These small deep ocean creatures are only about three centimeters
long, and that's about it down in the Mariana trench,
no secret treasures, hidden cities or sea monsters.
Next it's time for you to travel to the world's deepest sea volcano.
The West Mata volcano.
This underwater site is located Southwest of the Samoas.
You'll need to rent another submarine to travel down 1200 meters below the
surface. But since you just visited the Mariana trench,
it should be no problem for you.
If you're lucky the volcano would be active and you would enjoy seeing
lava fountains and glowing bubbles,
just be careful of all the debris that erupts into the ocean.
Both the West Mata volcano and the Mariana trench are natural,
deep points on earth. But what about something that's manmade?
The Penang goldmine is the deepest operating mind in the world
around 4,000 miners working it every day.
And despite safety precautions,
it's still risky in March, 2020,
a seismic event killed three miners who were three and a half kilometers
below the surface to get to the mine.
You'd need to travel to the Gauteng province. In South Africa,
you'd take the elevator known as a cage with 119 other
workers until it reaches two and a half kilometers below the earth surface.
As the elevator doors open, you'll notice the heat.
It's about 30 degrees and that's only because the mining company has
created a system to cool down the air.
Without fans blowing over a mixture of ice and salt,
the mind would be a whopping 60 degrees. Why?
Because you're so deep in the earth that it's inner heat is warming up the
surrounding atmosphere.
You'd only be two and a half kilometers underneath the earth surface to
go lower.
You'd need to walk or drive the rest of the way you'd be at the
bottom of the mine. When you reached four kilometers,
that's as deep as 10 empire state.
Luckily there are no cave creatures to worry about down here.
The only life down here other than the minors is monotypic bacteria.
While the opening goldmine is impressive.
All of the deepest points on earth are in oceans.
According to NASA,
over 80% of the oceans remain unmapped, unobserved,
and unexplored.
And if we want to continue to explore these areas,
we're going to need to take better care of our planet. For starters,
we could clean up our trash filled oceans.
Can you imagine a Mariana trench just brimming with garbage?
Well, that's a story for another. What if.